because you mentioned like the top gets
bigger with the Empire's
and you start taking things for granted
is uh some of this just human nature so
the concern with with China with
autocratic Nations
the concerned with the um the the Third
Reich
the Soviet Union
was that
fundamentally at the individual level
the humans involved at the top they
start becoming they're starting to lose
touch with the reality
in a way that no longer makes them I
guess that's the representation the
flexibility that you're referring to
well I'm I mean in a democracy
um you could change you can go as far
left or as far right you can change the
leaders easily and so the people don't
become
um and you know they pretty much only
have themselves to blame uh yeah you
know and one of the problems of that is
they may not choose the best leaders
um but they um they have that
flexibility so if vote and and you get
what you wanted in the case of the
autocratic let's say leaders and then
the movement from democracies to
autocracies
um what you see normally that movement
is that one of the systems is it is not
working let's say the democracy is not
effectively everybody's arguing with
each other and nobody's getting anything
done and you know like Mussolini the
trains are not running on time and that
would be the example geez this place has
gotten chaotic will somebody get in
through control and then they then you
get the autocratic
um and then he's autocratic enough to
boss people around and
um and then you follow those kinds of
orders and it's like a maybe a CEO in a
powerful company laundering around and
that could work well or it could work
badly you know most companies
are run as
um or like autocracies in a sense you
know there's the hierarchy and you the
command economy and that kind of thing
um and now that can work well or not
um but then what quite often when you
get the populist autocratic their
personality is something that they want
to fight
um and they become more nationalistic
um and they tend to become more
militaristic and human nature at that
stage
um lends itself to fighting there's an
arc here that when we think that it's we
think of a country
um and we say we and we think of a
country
um it's not true it's not like that
there are individuals who change one
generation dies and another generation
comes along and one of those arcs is
that
um
um the ones who have been through War
don't want to go to war and are more
happily you know willing to uh abide by
whatever the rules are as you get
Farther Along into that cycle and you
get a new generation and they forget
about wars and the horrors of Wars then
they
um and then they want to uh fight and so
you're seeing right now the immersion of
fight for right and and what that means
is you see it internally uh fight where
are you and fight for that thing and
they mean fight and then into externally
fight are you going to be uh the strong
one who will fight and win and that
develops on both sides this fight and
win and they decide is cheering each
other on into a war but that's comes by
those who really have not experienced
War because it comes in their part of
their lifetime
humans are fascinating humans are
fascinating and by the way Human Nature
has not changed over the thousands of
years so it's the it's so interesting
because like in doing this study and it
comes across in the study it's like
watching the same movie over and over
again
you you know you see the ark and you see
it happen over and over again the only
things that seem to change are the close
people wear and the Technologies
uh yeah and then somebody probably will
disagree with you about the clothes
maybe there's also Cycles within
Fashions maybe we're not even creative
there